CBS News senior foreign affairs
correspondent Margaret Brennan is
moderator of Face the Nation she spoke
yesterday for over an hour with iran's
Foreign Minister at the UN she joins us
from Washington Margaret good morning
good morning to you how does the the
downing or it's not clear whether there
actually was it down drone but I mean if
there was one down how is that gonna
affect the tensions that are already
high year well yeah Iran's trying to
dismiss it saying it didn't happen in
the first place but it is indisputable
that the military actions even though
they're limited they antagonize and they
make it difficult to find a diplomatic
way out
we know Frances president is talking to
both sides right now he is personally
trying to cool things off yesterday when
I spoke with iran's Foreign Minister who
you mentioned is in New York right now
he said the two countries were minutes
away from war last month when Trump
called President Trump called off that
military strike due to the downing of a
different drone in American one but
serif' is making a distinction here he
says Iran doesn't want to cause any
American casualties that's an important
distinction because it stops just short
of violating president Trump's redline
which is that the loss of a single US
life would trigger a military response
as for cooling tensions iran's Foreign
Minister told you that if the u.s. lifts
sanctions Iran would agree to
restrictions on its nuclear program but
that sounds a lot like what was in place
prior to all this so how exactly is that
going to defuse the situation well what
the foreign minister who negotiated that
2015 nuclear deal said is that Iran
would speed things up and put even more
restrictions on its existing nuclear
program they would allow for more
intrusive inspections but really the
White House is treating this as a
non-starter without the u.s. lifting
sanctions Zarif said he sees very little
chance of the u.s. countries of the two
countries beginning talks or of
President Trump and Iran's leader
meeting say in September when the two
were at the UN for those annual sessions
so last night we also saw the
administration put more sanctions on
Iran National Security Advisor John
Bolton raised
the bar saying Iran has to stop any and
all enrichment of uranium even though it
is currently permitted to have limited
amounts of that nuclear fuel under the
2015 international agreement that you
mentioned remember the u.s. pulled out
of that deal but the rest of the world
including Russia and China are still in
it and they are trying to find some way
to keep Iran's program under wraps all
of these skirmishes make it tougher to
find a way out
Margaret the u.s. is reportedly sending
500 more troops to the Persian Gulf does
that heighten tensions
well as David Martin has been reporting
the one of the reasons and one of the
justifications Saudi Arabia wants more
of a presence is because they are
concerned by these kind of antagonistic
actions and what you hear even Iran
warning of is that this can really
quickly escalate both Iran's supreme
leader and president Trump's say they do
not want war but you see these
skirmishes going right up to the line
within just a few yards of US ships and
it really could escalate quickly if
there is any kind of loss of US life
that is the line that the United States
has drawn in the sand here and it would
force President Trump's hand at least as
he has described the policy up to this
point Margaret Brennan thank you
Margaret